[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez Mateos está con
nosotros en el estudio Rosa buena mañana
de viernes ya nuestro último programa de
este año 2022 Rosa y abrimos por
supuesto esta revista de prensa con una
elección que resume muy bien la
actualidad de todo lo que ha sido este
año Buenos días Raúl Exactamente no y es
que la revista Time como era un poco de
esperar ha elegido al presidente
ucraniano vuelonski como persona del año
aslensky y al pueblo ucraniano no a su
coraje y a su resistencia y vamos a
citar algunas de las palabras del jefe
de redacción de esta publicación
estadounidense que explica cómo llegaron
a esta decisión dice que generalmente el
proceso para elegir a la persona del año
puede llegar a ser agonizante dice que
cada año se plantean si se inclinan
hacia la luz o hacia la oscuridad o se
alcanzan un punto intermedio sin embargo
dice la elección de este año fue la más
clara que se ya que la batalla por
Ucrania ya sea que la batalla por
Ucrania lo llene a uno de esperanza o de
miedo vuelo dimmer selensky impulsó al
mundo de una manera que no habíamos
visto en décadas dice el examen el
exactor entendió de manera innata que la
atención es la moneda más valiosa del
planeta y casi acaparó el mercado global
no dice el mercado de esta historia en
2022 es la esencia de lo que la persona
del año quiere capturar no y es que para
bien o para mal los las prioridades los
miedos o los talentos las debilidades de
cada uno de los individuos de los seres
humanos al final marcan los hechos
globales no dice por demostrar que el
coraje puede ser tan contagioso como el
miedo por animar a las personas y a las
naciones a unirse en defensa de la
libertad pues recordarle al mundo la
fragilidad de la democracia y de la paz
por vómimers de lensky y el espíritu de
Ucrania son la persona del año de 2022
de Time a pesar de todas las críticas
está ahí al frente El Cañón del
presidente y nunca digamos ha flaqueado
no en esta dura invasión rusa a su país
pero ahora Rosa repasemos algunas de las
portadas de las personas del año de la
revista Time en lo que ha sido de Esas
últimas décadas Sí porque nos vamos a
centrar en los últimos 20 años en que
esta elección ha estado plagada de jefes
de estado de líderes políticos no entre
algunas excepciones empecemos en 1999
porque me sorprendió particularmente que
ya en ese momento fuera Jeff bezos la
persona que Time eligió como eso como
personalidad del año recordemos una
iniciativa que empezó en 1927 en 2000 y
en 2004 fue George Bush el presidente
estadounidense quien ocupó esta portada
dedicada a la persona del año en 2003 el
año de la invasión de Irak fue el
soldado estadounidense finalmente en
2007 una sorpresa Vladimir Putin No ese
año fue persona del año de Time en 2008
y en 2012 fue Barak en 2016 fue Donald
Trump un año antes lo había sido Angela
Merkel en más adelante en 2018 fue jamal
cashoggie el periodista asesinato en la
embajada de Arabia saudí en Turquía en
2019 greta zamberg en 2020 Joe biden y
kamala Harris y Raúl no sé si tú
recuerdas Quién fue la persona del año
del año pasado antes de que aparezca
aquí detrás Ah ya llegó
más confieso Rosa que no sabía hasta que
vi Esa esa imagen que sin duda este año
también ha marcado la actualidad no
Claro que sí y es verdad yo creo que
este año también pues estaba Clara quien
podía ser esta persona del año el
presidente de Bolivia silencio y
volviendo un poco atrás Time también
elige entre otras cosas a los héroes del
año Rose y la elección también ha sido
bastante evidente y merecida quién
estamos hablando para tanto evidencia de
las mujeres de Irán no que han liderado
estas protestas masivas desatadas borra
la muerte de la joven maxa mini el 16 de
septiembre bajo custodia policial y que
desde entonces no es con el eslogan
mujer vida y Libertad desafían al
régimen al estatus quo de Teherán a
pesar de la mortal represión recordamos
que las cifras de fallecidos de Muertos
en el marco de la represión de las
protestas varían en función de las
organizaciones pero que Naciones Unidas
reconoce al menos a 300 personas muertas
no a manos de las autoridades de Irán y
a raíz de esto ya para concluir hoy de
Guardian precisamente saca una exclusiva
titulada las fuerzas iraníes disparan a
la cara y a los genitales de mujeres en
las protestas dicen los médicos no un
artículo que lo cierra una cita de soran
mas urnia activista kurda por los
Derechos Humanos que dice cada día
escuchamos sobre la muerte de alguna
persona herida que no fue al hospital
por miedo a que la resten bueno Rosa
delicada situación en la que se continúa
viviendo en irantas estas
manifestaciones que ya van a cumplir
cerca de tres meses luego del
fallecimiento de macsa Muchísimas
gracias como siempre diría que el lunes
nos vemos con más pero el año que viene
nos vemos con más claro que sí de
revista de prensa en directo América
como siempre ha sido un placer compartir
con usted Igualmente Raúl y Feliz año a
toda nuestra audiencia y felices fiestas
felices fiestas